the state has reported its highest
numbers of new infections yet for three
consecutive days and that number nearly
doubled to two to 450 yesterday from
Tuesday Republican Senator James
Lankford joins us now he plans to attend
that rally in Tulsa he's already there
in Oklahoma City
senator good morning we've got a lot to
get to so I want to jump right into it
nobody in this country is holding the
kind of indoor large gathering that the
president is planning for tomorrow not
megachurches
not sports leagues so why put public
safety at risk for a political rally
yeah this is a bell away good morning to
you as well this is a gathering that
like protests like other events like
shopping like malls that are open like a
lot of other things obviously there's a
lot of people that are there I said next
year yesterday on a plane that was full
of people coming back in there is a lot
of activity and a lot of interactions
and we've seen numbers as you just
reported coming up in Oklahoma coming up
in California coming up in different
places around the country so this is
this is a situation where people that
are high risk have got to make sure
they're taking care of themselves but
the challenge that we have right now is
isolation is what I heard from one of
the scientists right now what's going on
with isolations like holding a helium
balloon down you can hold it down and
hold the economy down and tell her not
to get out but as soon as you let your
hands off on it it's going to rise and
so it is a challenge for us we Center
the economy down forever
no and the question here is not really
about the economy of course people want
to get back outside but you know
protests or outdoor events and they're
not organized by something like a major
political party or the President of the
United States
grocery shopping clearly has to happen
people have to take care of their basic
needs a political rally is a voluntary
thing so from the outside looking in it
might appear to be putting politics over
public safety can you respond to that
directly no it's still it's still a
participation by choice event lots of
folks are gonna watch it on TV there's
an outdoor gathering at the venue as
well if people want to stay outside and
be able to watch it for folks that want
to come inside they can also do this we
have 80 testing sites set up around the
state and there's been an encouragement
all this past week from the Health
Department
if you're attending the rally come get
tested early and so you can evaluate
that for yourselves hand sanitizers
master provided their temperature check
sided so there are things that are going
on that are similar to other places on
this but again everyone needs to be able
to pay attention to this they can come
to the outside event they can come to
the inside event or they can stay home
and watch it yeah it's interesting that
the Trump administration or the Trump
campaign has had people sign liability
waivers so if they do get sick at this
event they won't hold the campaign
liable that's an acknowledgement of
something but but forget legally let's
talk morally this is your state these
are your constituents have you thought
about how you will feel if somebody gets
sick or god forbid dies yeah I think
everyone thinks about thought all the
time the thing that we've had in our
state that every other state has had is
a lot of questions about liability for
reopening restaurants are asking the
same question retail locations office
locations everyone's concerned about the
liability and how this is gonna work and
trying to be able to figure out does
this create a moment where there's going
to be additional lawsuits dealing with
things where people are trying to
re-engage in the safest way they can
again anyone attending it is a choice
for them to be able to attend this is an
optional event not a required event by
any means and people will attend on the
way that they are most comfortable in
the days ahead yeah well let's talk
about requirements for a second you said
face masks gonna be handed out but they
are not required inside the rally
the thing about face masks is that
they're not really for the individual
they're to protect others from the
individual so I'm curious in your
particular case have you made up your
mind will you be wearing a mask I'll be
wearing a mask most of the time I'll
have it off some of the time obviously
in a gathering like that it's hard to be
able to hear so it times I'm gonna have
to take it off so people can hear me and
I can hear them at times but I assume
that I'm gonna have it on a lot of time
interesting enough I got home late last
night back from DC I went to a
restaurant with my family I was the only
person in the restaurant that was
wearing a mask that is typical for a bad
thing I was no I'm saying that is the
thing Oklahoma's been through seven
weeks now of reopening it's only been in
the past
week that we've seen a bump in our
numbers and we know that's a
reengagement that's happening thankfully
our hospitalization numbers have only
slightly ticked up our death numbers are
still staying flat so we're learning how
to be able to manage this a little bit
better as we go but we we are always
attentive to what we can do to be able
to protect each other all right senator
I appreciate it and I'm glad we lingered
on the rally it is an important
milestone event we haven't had an event
like this in the United States since the
pandemic hit so we wish everyone the
best of luck and of course the best of
law of health as well senator thank you